what I want to introduce you to in this
video is a way to classify numbers as
either being even or being odd so what
does it mean to be even well an even
number is one where if you had that many
Donuts you could split it evenly between
two people
so even numbers are numbers that are
multiples of two so if you have two
Donuts you could split them if you had
two people you could give one doughnut
to each person for doughnuts you could
split that evenly with two people you
could they could each get two doughnuts
and then we can keep going all of the
multiples of two these are even numbers
eight ten twelve and of course we could
keep going on and on and on and on and
an easy way to spot an even number is
that it's ones place is going to be even
so for example the number thirty-two is
an even number because in the ones place
you have a to the number five million
nine hundred 77354 well that's an even
number because the ones place is even
now there's one number that's an
interesting one why some people
sometimes say well is this one really
even and that's the number zero and the
number zero is even because it is a
multiple of two how is it a multiple of
two well 0 times two is equal to zero so
zero is a multiple of two and so zero
for sure is an even number and then that
actually makes our looking at the ones
place idea hold up because a number like
a number like 150 is an even number and
we can look at the ones place up and say
oh we have a zero there and a zero is an
even number so if in the ones place you
have an even number you are looking the
whole thing is going to be an even
number so what are odd numbers well one
way to think about them is they're the
numbers that aren't even so not
multiples of two not multiples not
multiples of two so
some examples of odd numbers well one
three five seven nine and of course you
can go on and on and on and just like we
could look at the ones place to spot an
even number you can also look at the
ones place to spot an odd number the
number 59 well I haven't nine over here
in the ones place nine is odd so this is
going to be an odd number the number
1441 has a one in the ones place that is
an odd number so this whole thing is
going to be odd and so what's another
way why is it called odd well it'd be
hard to split one thousand one thousand
four hundred forty-one doughnuts you
can't split it evenly between two people
without breaking up a doughnut if you
wanted to leave the doughnuts hole one
person would have to get a large one
extra doughnut than the other person you
can't split it evenly the easiest way I
think about odd it's not a multiple of
two it's not even so another way it is
not it is not even so now that we know
what an odd or an even number is let's
think about what happens when we operate
on odd or even numbers so let's think in
particular actually let me move over to
the side right over here let me move
over right over here let's think whoops
fell off the screen let's think about
what happens if I take an even number an
even number plus another even number is
this number the sum is it going to be
even or odd well you could take some
examples if I say two plus six that is
going to be equal to eight
well eight is an even number if I say
fourteen plus four well that equals 18
once again eight in the ones place this
is an even number if I say a 150 150 six
plus plus 100 100 and I'm going to do a
simpler number plus plus four
that is equal to 160 zero in the ones
place this also is an even number so it
looks like all the examples that I've
done so far when I add an even to an
even I get an even number and I
encourage you to keep trying this out I
encourage you to keep trying try pick
some even number than another even
number add them together and you'll see
that you'll keep getting even numbers
and it makes sense because if you had
one number that's a multiple of two and
you add it to another number that's a
multiple 202 it makes sense that the sum
is going to be a multiple of two now
what happens if you add an odd and an
odd what happens if you add an odd
number plus another odd number well
let's try what is one plus three well
that's equal to four you actually get an
even number you had two odd numbers you
get an even number well maybe that was
just that special case but if I add 15
plus seven these are both odd numbers
when I add them together I get 22 I get
another even number this is interesting
if I take let me say 19 plus 3 actually
that gets us to 22 again we have an even
number this is this is interesting what
about what about let's see 23 plus 5
well that gets us to 28 once again get
an even number so the pattern that seems
to be forming here is that if I had it
an even plus and even I get an even but
also if I have an odd plus an odd then I
also get an even number and then once
again I encourage you to try out as many
numbers as you can to see if this
pattern holds and you will see that it
is true and odd plus an odd number is an
even now let's think about one last
combination what about and even what
about an even plus an odd and even plus
an odd so let's say I have 2 plus 1 2
plus 1 well what is that going to be
well that's going to be equal to 3
that's going to be an odd number well
what about what about 4 plus 3
our plus three well that's equal to
seven that's equal to an odd number and
so it looks like if I have an even plus
and odd and I've only tried out two
cases here but I encourage you to try
out many many many more to make sure
that you feel good about this but an
even and an odd is always going to give
you an odd so this is always going to
give you an odd so let's just remind
ourselves even numbers there are
multiples of two including zero odd
numbers are just numbers that aren't
multiples of two that aren't even and an
even plus and even is going to be equal
to an even and odd plus an odd is also
going to be equal to an even we saw that
we saw that multiple times but an even
plus an odd that is odd